على مدار العقدين الماضيين ، تم تحديد بداية
موسم الجولات الأوروبية من
خلال التأرجح الصحراوي
مع البطولات في أبو ظبي ودبي
والمملكة العربية
السعودية وقطر
على الرغم من أنني لم أتمكن من السفر
هناك في الأحداث الأولى لعام 2021.
فرصة التحدث إلى الرئيس
التنفيذي للجولف في دبي ، كريس ماي ،
لمعرفة مدى التغيير
على مدار العشرين عامًا التي قضاها في
المنطقة
عندما جئت لأول مرة بصراحة ، لم
أقم بزيارة دبي أبدًا قبل أن لا أعرف الكثير من
الناس  التي كانت في دبي
بصرف النظر عن العديد من
لاعبي الجولف المحترفين الذين لعبوا في صحراء دبي
الكلاسيكية وكان هذا حقًا كل ما أعرفه
عن دبي ، لكن
دبي كمدينة نمت بشكل كبير
وتطورت
كمركز عالمي حقيقي الآن مع معرفة
بعض من  أفضل الفنادق في العالم ،
بعض من أفضل ملاعب الجولف في
العالم ،
ربما تكون أفضل شركة طيران في العالم
، والبنية التحتية في المدينة
مذهلة ، حيث تعمل الصحراء الكلاسيكية الآن
منذ 32 عامًا ولكن الدورة التدريبية
والبطولة جاهزة  tty لا يمكن التعرف عليه الآن كيف
كانوا في ذلك الوقت ، لذا
كيف كان الحال في تلك السنوات الأولى
كريس نعم ، أعني
أنك محق تمامًا عندما
تم بناء نادي الإمارات للجولف لأول مرة ، أعني أنه كان
قبل مجيئي إلى دبي ولكن في
أواخر الثمانينيات كان  كيلومتر مربع من
العشب
في وسط الصحراء كان على بعد أميال
من المدينة
وهو الآن حقًا في قلب
المدينة
لذا فهو يظهر فقط ما حدث
في دبي من حيث التحول
ولكنك تعلم أنه حصل على مثل هذا
موقع رائع الآن بعد أن
أصبح من الصعب التغلب عليه ، لكن في تلك
السنوات الأولى كانت رحلة طويلة إلى
نادي الإمارات للجولف
وكنت ترى الجمال على جانب
الطريق
وأنت تعلم أنه كان مكانًا مختلفًا تمامًا
عندما كان  تم بناؤه لأول مرة
مع الوباء ، من الواضح أنه كان
عامًا مليئًا بالتحديات لمدينة تعتمد بشدة
على
السياحة مثل دبي ، فما مدى تأثير ذلك
على الأندية على مدار الاثني عشر
شهرًا الماضية ،
أعتقد أن الجميع مر
بعام صعب مع الوباء العالمي
وأه دو  من المؤكد أن باي لم
يتأثر ، فقد كان لدينا إغلاق كامل
وإغلاق
لنوادي الجولف في دبي لمدة 35 يومًا في
مارس وأبريل ،
لكن كان من المشجع جدًا أن نرى
بعد الإغلاق
أن شعبية لعبة الجولف قد مرت
عبر السقف
حيث  لقد تم ذلك في أجزاء كثيرة من
أوروبا والولايات المتحدة وحول
العالم ، ولكن
بشكل خاص في دبي ، كان إجمالي
عدد جولات الأعضاء في دبي التي تم لعبها
العام الماضي 12
زيادة مقارنة بعام 2019
، وذلك على الرغم من الإغلاق لمدة 35 يومًا
للعضوية التي قمنا ببيعها
ضاعف عدد
العضويات الجديدة العام الماضي التي فعلناها في عام
2019 ، حققت المتاجر المحترفة أداءً جيدًا حقًا ، لكن
لعبة الجولف كلعبة لديها فرصة رائعة
الآن
ليس فقط في دبي ولكن على مستوى العالم
لتحقيق أقصى استفادة من
تحويل هؤلاء الأشخاص حقًا إلى
لاعبو الجولف المتفرغون أعضاء بدوام كامل
لأن هناك
شهية كبيرة للجولف الآن
[موسيقى]
واحدة من أكبر السحوبات التي حصلت عليها في
نادي الإمارات هي لعبة الجولف الليلية ،
فكيف تغير ذلك؟  gs لأعضائك
توفر لعبة الجولف الليلية للناس
حقًا شيئًا مختلفًا بعض الشيء
لأن غالبية مباريات الجولف الليلية
يتم لعبها عبر تسعة حفر ، لذا فإن
لعب الجولف يستغرق ساعتين أقصر
بكثير مما يسهل على المزيد من
الأشخاص القيام به على
الأرجح.  ستين إلى سبعين
بالمائة من جولاتنا في الجولف الليلي عبارة عن
تسعة ثقوب فقط
، وهذا يعمل بشكل جيد حقًا إذا
وجد الناس أنها تتناسب مع جدولهم
الزمني جيدًا ، فيمكنهم ربطهم
بمشاهدة مباراة كرة قدم في وقت متأخر
عندما ينتهون
أو يشاهدون لعبة رجبي أو كريكيت
أيا كان.  قد يكون
الأمر كذلك ويعمل بشكل جيد حقًا
لأنه جلب المزيد من الأشخاص
إلى لعبة الجولف وأنت تعلم أنها
تحولت في هذا الصدد ،
فمن الواضح أنها منطقة مهمة جدًا
للجولة الأوروبية التي
تبدأ وتنهي موسمها هناك
الآن ، فماذا يعني أن يكون لديك
كلاسيك الصحراء والفعاليات الأخرى
في الشرق الأوسط ، نعم أعتقد أن
الصحراء الكلاسيكية
مهمة للغاية أه في دبي
، إنها الأقدم والأقدم  أكثر
بطولات الجولف التقليدية في
المنطقة
أه وقد وضعت دبي حقًا على الخريطة
والمنطقة على الخريطة
التي تعلم أنها أقيمت في ملعب مانجولاس للجولف ،
وهو أول ملعب غولف عشبي
في الشرق الأوسط ، أبطال الجولف العظماء
الذين فازوا
من  Sevi إلى rory ،
إنه حقًا من لعب الجولف على مدار
الثلاثين عامًا الماضية ، لذلك كان من
المهم للغاية أن تعرف حقًا عرض
دبي للعالم
، ونتيجة لذلك أعتقد أننا
أصبحنا الآن تعرف  تأرجح الشرق الأوسط
مع البطولة في أبو ظبي ودبي
ثم المملكة العربية السعودية ، لذا فقد أدى
هذا النوع من بطولة الجولف الرائدة
في صحراء دبي الكلاسيكية حقًا
إلى نمو هائل
في لعبة الجولف المحترفة في هذه المنطقة